the pentagon spokesman just said
thousands of american citizens remain
trapped in afghanistan tonight he said
he didn't know the exact number that
it's just thousands
many of them can't apparently get to the
border because the taliban control the
roads according to the white house isis
is also operating near the airport but
today joe biden's flak denied that any
of those american citizens in
afghanistan are quote stranded
i think it's irresponsible to say
americans are stranded they are not we
are committed to bringing americans who
want to come home home we are in touch
with them via phone via text via email
via any way that we can possibly reach
americans to get them home if they want
to return home there are no americans
stranded is the white house's official
position on what's happening in
afghanistan i'm just calling you out for
saying that we are stranding americans
in afghanistan
you know you've reached a peak lunacy
when the biden administration calls
other people irresponsible
okay
so what should we know about afghanistan
what is actually happening
there right now laura logan is one of
you who does know she hosts laura logan
has no agenda on fox nation she lived in
afghanistan she joins us saint laurent
thanks so much for coming on so what
should we know what can we trust about
what's actually happening tonight in
afghanistan
well as you know tucker i try to focus
on what are really the defining things
right because there's a lot of
misinformation and propaganda being
pushed by the administration and by the
taliban and so on but what is at the
heart and the core well
for example the most important thing
that i think americans should understand
is that both this country's enemies and
the biden administration want you to
accept that there is nothing that can be
done
that this outcome that you see where the
united states world superpower is
humiliated defeated and shamed on the
world stage that it bows at the knee you
know takes a knee and bows at the feet
of terrorists that uh we have to
recognize the taliban as the legitimate
government of afghanistan that afghans
haven't fought and aren't fighting right
now that there's no resistance
this foregone conclusion right is what
they want you to accept because as long
as we're talking and arguing about how
many american citizens are left behind
and so on we're not talking about the
fact that um all of these decisions that
brought us here are political every
single one of them yes there were many
failures along the way but the framework
within the generals you know operates is
a political framework the
commander-in-chief is a politician not a
military man and they love to remind us
all of that so the political decisions
that resulted in this outcome have not
changed one bit there is nothing that is
altered they're not using any of the
levels of power in any dimension not
political not diplomatic not economic
not security wise not military so you
have to look at that and say well okay
they're getting the outcome they want
because they could bomb the taliban into
the stone age right like that they could
you know destroy all those weapons that
are in place they could tell pakistan to
stop sea synthesis right now or we're
cutting off the money and we're putting
sanctions on you they could tell the
qataris stop doing these big you know
evacuations of afghan women the robotics
team and the mountaineering team you
know when you're funding the taliban and
you finance this invasion you know use
the levers of your power and then let's
not forget the advanced military
technology that the united states
military has i mean the kind of things
we have thermal drones that can see
through walls okay
you know throughout the entire war in
afghanistan none of this capability has
been used and so that's a broader
question as to why not but the real
question here is why are we accepting
that all of these women in afghanistan
you know are condemned to a death
sentence right and a life of that all
their dreams are obliterated when we
could actually do something about it you
know the chinese are you know they're
crowing today they're all over xinhua
the the state news agency and they're
mocking joe biden they're mocking the
united states you know and so we are
accepting this defeat that puts this
country in jeopardy and the second thing
that i think is a defining real question
here is we are also accepting the idea
that if you criticize this you're
advocating to stay in afghanistan and uh
that is false there are many other
options without staying in afghanistan
and most importantly this is not just
about afghanistan this doesn't just
empower al qaeda and the terrorists in
afghanistan it empowers every enemy the
united states has it doesn't just
discourage the allies we have in
afghanistan it tells every nation on
earth we are a terrible ally with
friends like us you don't need enemies
we can't do this alone for our security
globally we need friends when we needed
help we went to the afghans and we said
please help us and i'll tell you what an
afghan leader said to me today he said
every meeting with the u.s began with we
won't betray you again we won't abandon
you again we made a mistake after the
cold war and what promise you this time
we won't do it and then the iranians
would come into the next meeting and
they would say america will abandon you
again we are your neighbor we'll be here
when they do and what you're seeing is
the biden administration proving that
every enemy of america and everything
they've ever said about this country is
the truth
there's going to be a major realignment
obviously and i agree with your point
that just because you criticize this
does not mean you're arguing for another
20 years of occupation there are other
options laura logan i appreciate your
coming on we have the most interesting
conversations
ever on this subject with laura on a
brand new episode of chucker crossing
today for over an hour you can stream it
on fox nation and we hope you will laura
thanks
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else